zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
an diesem montagmorgen zu beginn einer
woche in der der bundestag einen neuen
kanzler wählen wird am mittwoch olaf
scholz und heute wird er vorstellen wer
von der spd seine ministerinnen und
minister im kabinett sein werden wir
übertragen die pressekonferenz aus dem
willy-brandt-haus in wenigen minuten
gleich live aus berlin können vielleicht
schon mal sehen dass die kollegen dort
mit den vorbereitungen beschäftigt sind
die journalistinnen und journalisten
sind alle schon da aber von der spd noch
niemand darauf warten wir und darauf
welche namen der nun bekannt gegeben
werden und einige sind ja spekuliert
worden und inzwischen ist ein bisschen
durchgesickert wer es denn
wahrscheinlich werden könnte wir blicken
in die agenturen und stellen fest dass
sowohl die db als auch reuters
übereinstimmend melden dass karl
lauterbach neuer
bundesgesundheitsminister werden soll
das war ja lange spekuliert worden dann
hieß es olaf scholz und er verstehen
sich nicht wirklich aber
offenbar wurde hier eine entscheidung
getroffen zumindest melden dass zwei
agenturen übereinstimmend und wir warten
ab ob es denn dann auch in wenigen
minuten bestätigt wird über die anderen
nahmen über die spekuliert wird sprechen
wir heute in der sendung mit professor
andrea römmele sie ist
politikwissenschaftlerin an der hertie
school of governance und jetzt
zugeschaltet während wir warten frau
professor rummel guten morgen kevin
kühnert der designierte generalsekretär
hat gesagt wir werden heute einen guten
tag haben und ich glaube es wird viele
menschen im land geben die mit dem kopf
nicken und sagen das kann sich sehen
lassen sind sie da genau so optimistisch
was die spd ministerinnen und minister
angeht
ja erst auch einmal guten morgen von mir
ja ich bin da eigentlich auch relativ
optimistische olaf scholz und sein team
haben sich zeit gelassen hier zu
sondieren mit welchen ministerin
minister man ins feld geht natürlich
spielt eine große rolle
der proporz
weibliche ministerin
solle es sollen vertreten sein er möchte
hat er ja immer gesagt mit einem
paritätischen
kabinett staaten jetzt ist
durchgesickert dass lauterbach auch
gesundheitsminister werden soll das
feiert die ganz große spekulation ob er
es wird oder nicht es gab viele gründe
die uns beobachterinnen und beobachter
dazu bewegt haben zu sagen er wird es
nicht es gab genau so viele gründe die
uns dazu bewegt haben zu sagen ja eher
wirkt es und ich denke das wird viele
bürgerinnen und bürger auch
werden viele begrüßen weil er doch das
rationale gesicht der pandemie war und
ist hat immer wieder erklärt warum wir
dort sind wo wir sind was die maßnahmen
sein müssen und seine seine
wissenschaftliche kompetenz in dem
bereich hat ihm doch enorm viel zuspruch
gegeben nicht nur in der spd sondern
auch überparteilich in der bevölkerung
und ich denke das war sicherlich auch
einer der beweggründe von olaf scholz
internets endlich zu minister zu berufen
wenn ich hier in den jet gruppe frau
professor römmele dann sehen wir dass
die personalie lauterbach in der tat
auch die es die die menschen am meisten
interessiert hier schreibt ein user
namens jesus 7 über youtube lauterbach
ist derjenige der wo den job am besten
oder gut machen wird also viele daumen
hoch hier im chat für karl lauterbach
und an dieser stelle nochmal die
aufforderung schreiben sie uns ihre
kommentare und fragen wie immer in die
kommentare oder an die bekannte und
jetzt eingeblendete e mail adresse frau
professor rummel die frage mit einem
blick nach berlin spare ich mir für nach
der pressekonferenz die ich gerade
stellen wollte denn wir sehen olaf
scholz
langsam der
den raum im willy brandt haus betritt
wir sehen die zukünftigen minister
hubertus heil kann man sehen svenja
schulze kann man sehen und in der tat
karl lauterbach und vorne ist saskia
esken die noch parteivorsitzende und
auch die zukünftige denn sie will er
weitermachen und jetzt geht's los
sie alle hier sind jetzt an einem ganz
bestimmten moment vor der bevorstehenden
regierungsbildung die in dieser woche
stattfinden soll erinnern wir uns noch
einen moment zurück am tag der
bundestagswahl ist die
sozialdemokratische partei stärkste
partei geworden und daraus haben wir die
chance gemacht eine regierung zu bilden
zusammen mit den grünen und der fdp wir
haben intensiv wochen lang verhandelt
über einen koalitionsvertrag zustande
gekommen ist und mittlerweile seine
überwältigende zustimmung bekommen hat
bei der sozialdemokratischen partei und
bei der fdp und da bin ich sicher heute
auch von den mitgliedern der grünen
bekommen wird und jetzt geht es darum
die letzten entscheidungen zu treffen
und eine der letzten runden von
entscheidungen da kommen noch ein paar
seien jetzt die bundesministerin und
bundesminister zu benennen die ich den
bundespräsidenten als
sozialdemokratische minister und
minister vorschlagen möchte für die
regierung die wir jetzt bilden worden
und ich erlaube mir gleich ein paar
bemerkungen dazu zu machen die spd hat
in diesem kabinett siegen ministerinnen
und minister zu besetzen und sie damit
zu betrauen die geschicke unseres landes
voranzubringen
wir sind uns sicher dass es richtig ist
dass in dieser zusammensetzung wir vier
frauen und drei männer vorschlag worden
das entspricht der gesellschaft in der
wir leben in der männer und frauen
jeweils die hälfte der bevölkerung
ausmachten und wo es dann auch dazu
gehören muss dass die frauen die hälfte
der macht haben und das ist das was wir
unbedingt anstreben und deshalb bin ich
sehr stolz darauf dass es uns nun
gelingt das auch zu realisieren
werden das dann alles noch weiter
fortsetzen wie ich angekündigt hat mit
der benennung von
parlamentarischen staatssekretären und
staatssekretären staatsministerin alles
das kommt noch jetzt geht es um die
bundesministerin und bundesminister
als erstes möchte ich ihnen hier
vorschlagen eine frau die etwas ganz
besonderes werden sollen nämlich die
erste innenministerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland aus meiner sicht ist das
auch zeit dass wir eine so schwierige
aufgabe die viel mit der sicherheit
unseres landes verbundenes in die hände
an der erfahren und mit dem thema
bestens bekannten frau aus deutschland
blicken ich werde dazu vorschlagen dass
nancy faeser das machen soll sie kennen
sie als fraktions und landesvorsitzende
der hessischen spd aber sie sollten
wissen dass sie eine langjährige
politische laufbahn hinter sich hat und
ein ganz ganz wichtiger teil davon
immerhin zwölf jahre war sie die
innenpolitische sprecherin der
hessischen landtagsfraktion
das heißt das ist genau ihr thema das
sie niemals verlassen hat vom herzen
sowieso nicht auch als sie vorsitzende
der fraktion im hessischen landtag wurde
und auch natürlich nicht in all den
schwierigen jahren muss darum ging den
hessischen nsu untersuchungsausschuss zu
begleiten nancy faeser wird eine sehr
sehr gute in ministerin in deutschland
und ich freue mich dass sie mir zugesagt
hat
ja ganz herzlichen dank ich freue mich
über diese ehre die menschen in unserer
republik haben zu recht den anspruch
dass wir für ihre innere sicherheit
sorgen dass kann man vor allen dingen
mit gut ausgebildeten gut ausgestatteten
personal bei den sicherheitsbehörden
insbesondere natürlich bei der
bundespolizei ein besonderes anliegen
wird mir seien die größte bedrohung die
derzeit unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung habt den
rechtsextremismus zu bekämpfen
das wird mir ein besonderes anliegen
sein und ich bedanke mich hat sich für
diese erde
ein zweites möchte ich ihnen fast schon
ein schlachtross 1 niedersachsen rast
vorstellen dass wir wieder in das
kabinett
berufen wollen hubertus heil als
bundesminister für arbeit und soziales
er hat wirklich eine ganz ganz
erfolgreiche bilanz in den letzten vier
jahren
vorzulegen er hat dafür gesorgt dass in
deutschland die grundrente möglich wurde
hat dafür gesorgt dass wir in bestimmten
bereichen unseres arbeitslebens schlimme
ausbeutungsverhältnisse geherrscht haben
neue verhältnisse etablieren können die
besser recht und ordnung auf dem
arbeitsmarkt
entsprechende an die schlimmen
verhältnisse in der fleischbranche und
der fleischindustrie oder an die
wirklich schwierigen schicksals
situationen der paketboten in
deutschland wir kennen ihn als
hartnäckig und klug als jemand der sein
wort macht aber der sich genau für die
menschen und die bürgerinnen und bürger
unseres landes einsetzt um die es geht
wenn man bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales ist und auf ihn warten große
neue aufgaben die sich aus den
verständigen der kunst ständig um der
künftigen regierungsparteien ergeben ich
will nur erinnern an die durchsetzung
eines erhöhten mindestlohns von 12 euro
und ich will nur erinnern an die
wichtige aufgabe jetzt stabile renten
für die zukunft zu sichern zwei ganz
große herzens projekte von mir aber ich
bin sicher auch von den meisten bürgern
und bürger hubertus heil wird weiter ein
sehr guter arbeit zum sozialminister
sein
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
ich bin stolz meiner
sozialdemokratischen partei sehr dankbar
dass ich diese wichtige aufgabe für
unser land fortführen kann als aber die
sozialminister stellt man in diesen
zeiten vor großen herausforderungen
ich bin mir dessen sehr bewusst hier
geht es um mehr respekt und mehr
leistungsgerechtigkeit
stichwort mindestlohn führen und
anständige arbeitsbedingungen
es geht uns als spd aber auch um einen
starken und verlässlichen sozialstaat
der als partner für die bürgerinnen und
bürger da ist ähnlich vor der nase
sondern zur seite steht deshalb werden
wir das bürgergeld einführen und wir
werden für soziale sicherheit und
leistungsgerechtigkeit auch durch
stabile renten sorgen hier ist zudem
wichtig dass wir in diesem wandel von
wirtschafts und arbeitswelt dafür sorgen
dass die beschäftigten von heute auch
die chance haben die arbeit von morgen
zu machen deutschland muss eine
weiterbildungs ermöglicht werden und wir
wollen dass alle menschen diesem land
teilhaben können unabhängig von
geschlecht herkunft oder eben auch der
frage ob man eine beeinträchtigung hat
oder nicht wir wollen eine gesellschaft
die zusammenhält ich freue mich auf die
arbeit in dieser fortschritts koalition
und ich werde mit all dem was ich kann
vermag für sozialen fortschritt in
deutschland arbeiten in dieser regierung
herzlichen dank
sicherheit wird dieser regierung in den
händen starker frauen liegen deshalb
will ich als
bundesminister der verteidigung
christine lambrecht vorschlagen dass die
in dem landstrich
ist eine erfahrene politikerin einer
erfahrenen ministerin die gegenwärtig
sogar zwei ressorts leitet und das ist
schon mal eine der ganz ganz großen
kompetenzen und fähigkeiten den mann
verfügen über die man verfügen muss wenn
man das verteidigungsressort leiten will
das ist ein großes ressort das eine
wichtige verantwortung für unser land
und für unsere sicherheit hat die frauen
und männer in der bundeswehr haben auch
verdient dass jemand vorne an steht im
ministerium der sich für sie einsetzte
ein herz für sie hat und er versorgt
dass sie gut ausgestattet werden aber
die es auch kann und das ist bei
christine lambrecht exakt der fall sie
hat in all den aufgaben die sie zuletzt
wahrgenommen hat gezeigt welche großen
fähigkeiten in ihr stecken und sie wird
eine ganz ganz bedeutende
verteidigungsministerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein
[Applaus]
dann für viele wird die nominierung als
verteidigungsministerin eine
überraschung sein für mich ist es
erstens ein großer vertrauensbeweis
lieber olaf scholz wofür ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken möchte und es ist
eine herausforderung wer mich kennt und
bei olaf scholz ist das der fall da war
es dass ich gerne große
herausforderungen auch annehme und
genauso weil ich das auch in diesem amt
tun die soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr haben es verdient dass wir
sie mit anerkennung und mit respekt
deswegen mit anerkennung und respekt
begegnen und ich möchte da ausdrücklich
auch die reservisten mit einbeziehen wir
erleben ja was großartiges
beeindruckendes leisten wir lebens jetzt
in der korona pandemie haben sie aber
auch im sommer beim hochwasser im aartal
erlebt und deswegen müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass nicht nur das ganze
ausgedrückt wird in barth links und dann
auch ein tat und dazu gehört beschaffung
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass sie
entsprechend ausgestaltet sind wir
müssen das beschaffungswesen
modernisieren wir müssen diesen beruf
attraktiv machen damit der demokratie
fest der block demographie fest ist und
eine herausforderung wird sein aber die
ist ganz wichtig dass wir dafür sorgen
dass auslandseinsätze in zukunft ständig
evaluiert werden immer wieder überprüft
werden und auch einer exit-strategie
vorhanden ist wir haben gesehen beim
afghanistan-einsatz wie wichtig das ist
und dafür will ich mich einsetzen
deswegen freue ich mich auf diese große
herausforderung
ein thema ist in diesen tagen unser zwei
jahren aller munde und ein
thema macht viele besorgt seitdem die
pandemie in der welt ausgebrochen ist
doch unser land erreicht hat wir sind
jetzt so lange schon dabei zu versuchen
die virusinfektion im griff zu bekommen
immer wieder mit erfolgen und immer
wieder mit rückschlägen und natürlich
haben wir bei dieser gelegenheit
festgestellt wie gut es ist dass wir ein
ordentliches gesundheitssystem haben
aber wie viel besser es wäre wenn wir
noch viel besseres gesundheitssystem
hätten bei dem all die schwächen und
schwierigkeiten die wir nun noch mal neu
kennengelernt haben nicht mehr da wären
und wir uns auf dieses gesundheitssystem
mit aller kraft verlassen können als
bürgen und bürger das ist glaube ich
auch ganz wichtig wenn wir daran denken
dass so viele dort arbeiten die träge
kräfte die pflegerinnen und pfleger die
ärzte ärzte gibt mit ganzem herzen dabei
sind und es auch verdient haben dass das
eine erste priorität in der politik der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird ein
gutes gesundheitssystem mit guten
arbeitsbedingungen und unten angeboten
für die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
etablieren und für mich ist ganz wichtig
dass wir dann natürlich auch im blick
haben dass die pandemie noch lange nicht
vorbei ist und deshalb haben sich anders
kann man das gar nicht sagen bestimmt
die meisten bürgern und bürger dieses
landes gewünscht dass der nächste
gesundheitsminister vom fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er karl
lauterbach heißt er wird es
vielen dank uhr laufen ich da ein
bisschen langsamer für das vertrauen der
partei ganz herzlich bedanken für diese
wichtige aufgabe aber ich möchte mich
bedanken für die vielen zustimmenden
worte die aus der bevölkerung bekommen
habe also dann wichtiges amt werden wir
müssen diese pläne bekämpfen die fahne
liebe länger dauern als viele denken wir
werden das aber schaffen inseln wird die
zentrale rolle spielen aber nicht nur
sie werden darüber hinaus das
gesundheitssystem stärken oder es hat
eben schon darauf hingewiesen mit uns
wird es keine leistungskursen im
gesundheitswesen geben ganz im gegenteil
sie werden das system wieder robuster
machen es sind stolz auf ein gutes
gesundheitssystem wir werden das
benötigen wir werden den kampf mit der
fahne nie gewinnen und für waldhof
handeln werden wir besser gerüstet zu
sein als wir für diese gewesen sind
vielen dank für diese zustimmung vielen
dank für das vertrauen
[Applaus]
eine der ganz ganz großen
herausforderung dieses landes dafür zu
sorgen dass wir genügend und bezahlbaren
wohnraum haben das ist ein thema das die
höheren und bürger jeden tag um treibt
viele machen sich sorgen ob sich die
wohnung in der sie jetzt wohnen noch
leisten können ob sie wenn sie umziehen
müssen eine neue bezahlbare wohnung
finden ob es überhaupt genügend gibt und
ob das mit den bedürfnissen
übereinstimmt die man hat an den orten
wo man lebt und arbeitet
das ist nicht so einfach und deshalb
haben wir uns dafür eingesetzt dass
diese wichtige aufgabe wieder die
bedeutung bekommt sie schon einmal
insbesondere den ersten jahrzehnten der
nachkriegsgeschichte deutschlands hatte
und haben dafür gerungen dass die
künftige bundesregierung wieder ein
eigenes ministerium bekommt es geht um
viele viele wohnungen es geht um viele
geförderte wohnung und ich möchte
vorschlagen dass klara geywitz die
nächste bundesministerin wird die das
thema bauen für sich zur aufgabe macht
sie hat die erfahrung dazu die hat in
der kommunalpolitik in der
stadtverordnetenversammlung genau die
themen verarbeitet sie hat als landes
landtagsabgeordnete sich mit den fragen
aus der perspektive der länder
auseinander gesetzt und sie hat auch
viele erfahrungen der führung der
sozialdemokratischen partei entbrannt wo
ich gewonnen und ist jetzt
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende der
spd klara geywitz ist für mich eine der
ganz talentierten politikerin dieses
landes und deshalb will ich froh dass
wir diese schwere aufgabe
wo soll man richtig was konkretes geht
anpacken will anpacken mit vielen
männern und frauen auf den bau die dafür
sorgen dass es wieder genug wohnungen
gibt
ich will danken die schweine
sozialdemokratischen partei aber auch
ganz persönlich bei olaf scholz das
mitglied des bundeskabinetts sein darf
ein bundeskabinett was paritätisch
besetzen ist ein thema für das ich seit
jahren schneite und das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen für alle frauen in
diesem land die aufgabe die vor uns
liegt ist riesig 400.000 wohnungen davon
100.000 gefördert zu bauen jährlich das
ist eine herausforderung für die planung
aber auch für die bauindustrie und mit
blick auf die klimaziele müssen wir dies
auch
klimaschonend machen energie sparen das
wird auch einen beitrag dazu leisten die
ohnehin schon hohe qualität der
deutschen bauindustrie noch weiter zu
verbessern deswegen werde ich mich auch
stark machen zum beispiel für das thema
thema bauforschung denn wieso wohl
irgend werden gebraucht frauen männer
junge familien aber auch seniorinnen auf
dem land brauchen barrierefreie wohnung
und ein klima was alle frauen im
kabinett 1 das ist das thema sicherheit
die mieterinnen und mieter im life
brauchen sicherheit dass sie nicht aus
ihrer wohnung vertrieben werden weil die
mieten übermäßig steigen sie brauchen
sicherheit dass sie auch im alter noch
in ihrer wohnung leben können und nicht
ausziehen müssen weil sie nicht mehr den
vierten stock kommt und sie brauchen
auch sicherheit dass sie in einem staat
der sich so gestaltet dass sie gerne
weiter da würden wo sie seit jahrzehnten
wohnen das ist eine große
herausforderung auf die ich mich sehr
freue in hessen dann
[Applaus]
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung ein ganz wichtiges thema für
deutschlands verordnung in der welt wir
haben eine aufgabe nicht nur für uns
sondern auch für die übrige welt und das
wird genau in diesem ministerium
wahrgenommen wir müssen sicherstellen
dass es überall gute
entwicklungsperspektiven gibt wir müssen
hunger und armut bekämpfen aber wir
müssen auch dafür sorge tragen dass zum
beispiel nicht unsere welt bedroht wird
durch den klimawandel und die
klimaflüchtlinge die daraus erwachsenen
mögen deshalb ist das eine sehr zentrale
herausforderung und ich bin sehr froh
dass die sozialdemokratische portal die
ehre hat dieses ministerium zu besetzen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass die
svenja schulze genau die richtige
ministerin für diese aufgabe ist sie hat
gerade zuletzt weil der klimakonferenz
in glasgow noch mal gezeigt wie sehr sie
international vernetzt es wie sehr sie
internationales parkett beherrscht was
er eben auch zu dieser aufgabe dazu
gehört aber wie sehr sie auch globale
themen die uns dann auch hierzulande
berühren immer schon umgetrieben haben
und mit der erfahrung im rücken die sie
in ihrer bisherigen aufgabe als
umweltministern gewonnen hat ist sie
genau die richtige für dieses ressort
ich bin sehr dankbar dass svenja schulze
nun die dritte sozialdemokraten im amt
der
entwicklungshilfeministerin sein wird
und ich bin sehr stolz das ist anja
schulz ist
es ist mir eine große ehre im gästen
kabinett scholz den bereich der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und der
entwicklungspolitik zu verantworten die
entwicklungspolitik hat eine lange
tradition in der spd wir sind solche
namen wie erhard eppler egon bahr marie
schlei und heidemarie wieczorek zeul
verbunden und ich freue mich jetzt als
sozialdemokrat in diesem bereich weiter
verantworten zu können ich hab in
deutschland mich für die transformation
für die klimaveränderung für die ganzen
veränderungen die wir vor uns haben in
den letzten jahren engagiert und jetzt
geht es um die internationale
solidarität und die globale ebene dich
in zukunft verantworten werde das ist
eine große ehre und ich bin sehr froh
dabei sein zu können
ja dann gehört zu einer richtigen
regierung auch ein chef des
bundeskanzleramtes das wird niemand
überraschen wird worten schnitt sein und
ich muss und will an dieser stelle gerne
sagen dass ich mich bedanken für die
langjährige zusammenarbeit die wir
bisher hatten und dass sich deshalb auch
weiß dass das reisegeschäft dass dort
betrieben wird auch von wolfgang schmidt
gut voran getrieben wird denn es muss ja
alles miteinander
funktionieren was die regierung all die
unterschiedlichen parteien die
unterschiedlichen ministerien
voranbringen wollen und das ist eine
gute gute unterstützung wenn das mit all
der kompetenz und erfahrung der letzten
jahre dann an dieser stelle fortgesetzt
werden kann dankbar dass er diese
aufgabe wahrnimmt
auch ich bin natürlich dankbar und ich
freue mich darauf die aufgabe des chefs
bundeskanzler ist es mitzuhelfen dass
die regierung gut arbeiten kann das will
ich machen mit den hier anwesenden
kolleginnen und kollegen aber natürlich
auch mit dem minister und ministerin der
grünen und der fdp das gilt aber auch
für die zusammenarbeit mit dem deutschen
bundestag dem bundesrat und den 16
ländern wir erleben das jetzt in der
korona pandemie wie wichtig das ist und
auch darüber hinaus bei der großen
transformations- aufgabe beim ausbau von
windenergie und solar energie kommt es
darauf an dass die zusammenarbeit mit
den ländern und klappt und ich will
dafür sorgen dass olaf scholz den rücken
frei hat dann wird er das machen kann
was er versprochen hat ordentlich zu
regieren
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
ist mir eine besondere freude gewesen am
samstag dass diese demokratische partei
den koalitionsvertrag dieser kommenden
ampel zu fast 99 prozent zugestimmt hat
und heute morgen macht es mich sehr froh
in einer reihe mit
herausragenden fähigen
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
zu stehen die gerade eben vom präsidium
auch einstimmig bestätigt worden sind
wir sind also stehen als sed mit großer
freude an der seite und hinter diesen
ministerinnen und ministern und
natürlich unsere
nächste altkanzler olaf scholz die
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
werden gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wir
endlich wissensbasierte
krisenbewältigung haben dass er eine
gesundheitsversorgung bekommen dass wir
am arbeitsmarkt und der sozialstaat
bekommen der die ins 21 jahrhundert
passen wir werden für
bezahlbares und klimagerechtes wohnen
sorgen wir sorgen für innere und äußere
sicherheit für einen modernen staat und
wir sorgen auch für gerechte teilhabe
nachhaltige teilhabe in aller welt und
natürlich auch in deutschland es folgt
nicht ganz besonders heute diese
minister und ministerinnen regel auch
mit präsentieren zu dürfen als
parteivorsitzender
ja wir sind angetreten für kontinuität
und wandel wir haben große aufgaben vor
uns und kontinuität und wandel haben wir
nicht nur mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
geschrieben und mit dem was wir uns
jetzt vorgenommen haben sondern für
kontinuität und wandel steht auch dieses
künftige kabinett beziehungsweise in
diesem fall der sozialdemokratische teil
dieses kabinett und ich bin sehr froh
über dieses team das jetzt hier auf der
bühne steht und ich habe es ja schon mal
gesagt für mich ist das ein schlusspunkt
aber was für eine schöne und
schlusspunkt kann es geben wenn man
gleichzeitig sehen kann welchen anfang
ist jetzt gibt und dass heute ist der
tag an dem nikolaus ist
ich habe das glück gehabt dass der
nikolaus nicht ganz flüssig geworden ist
ich wünsche euch allen viel glück
die bühne ist voll und wir fangen an mit
einigen wenigen fragen martin greife vom
handelsblatt die erste das mikrofon bis
dahin kommen genau
was in weilheim slot der stolz dass
lauterbach jetzt gesundheitsminister
wird war das also der lange lange zeit
geleckte plan den sie haben oder ist das
ist die entscheidung wirklich erst in
den vergangenen tagen gefallen und
zweite frage ist dann noch ein paar
weitere posten vorne alles soll ja
angeblich pa chefin werden auch eine
nachfolge für weidmann muss gefunden
werden die psychischen entscheidung
alle dinge werden gut vorbereitet und
werden lange vorbereitet und sie kommen
dann ans licht des tag an das tageslicht
wenn es so weit ist das ist jetzt den
riegel der frauen männer die der
künftigen bundesregierung angehören
werden die anderen entscheidungen werden
jeweils dann bekannt gemacht wenn sie
ansteht ich will das noch mal sagen auch
im hinblick auf entscheidungen die jetzt
um über institutionen gehen die nicht
unmittelbar der bundesregierung zu
gehören das wird natürlich nicht jetzt
vor der bildung der regierung
stattfinden sondern dann wenn es jeweils
auf der tagesordnung sich wiederfindet
und da sind ja auch selbst
verwaltungsstrukturen beteiligt deshalb
macht es auch keinen sinn sich zu
irgendwelchen spekulationen zu äußern
die nächste frage ob es interne liegen
süddeutsche zeitung
ja ich hätte zwei fragen wenn ich darf
als war die erste sie haben ja gesagt es
soll parität geben aber wenn von 17
posten 8 mit frauen besetzt sind ist das
meiner meinung nach nicht die hälfte und
die zweite teil frage ist die spd hat
ihren weiß ich ja auch sehr fehlen
direktmandaten im osten in den fünf
neuen bundesländern zu verdanken wenn
ich ihr kabinett anschaue da ist dann
eine frau aus dem osten dabei ist das
nicht angehe ist das angemessen aus
ihrer sicht ja schönen dank für die
frage in der tat die parität ist mir
wichtig dass wir werden von 16 ministern
und ministern acht männer und acht
frauen sein und selbstverständlich wenn
es dann noch ein bundeskanzler geben der
für alle gemeinsam zuständig ist und
sich für diese fragen einsetzt ich
glaube dass es auch gut ist dass die
sozialdemokratische partei sich
entschlossen hat vier ministerinnen und
drei minister in das kabinett zu
entsenden und das ist glaube ich auch im
zeichen dafür dass das tief verankert
ist und das nicht nur von mir so gesehen
wird sondern von einem und besonders
stolz bin ich darauf dass gerade so
ressorts bei denen das keineswegs in der
tradition licht jetzt von frauen geführt
werden mache das noch mal hier klar da
stehen sie die
künftige innenministerin die künftigen
verteidigungsminister die künftige
bauministerin aus meiner sicht ein ganz
ganz bemerkenswertes zeichen und
vielleicht auch das noch es ist gut dass
wir an die große
vertretung all der unterschiedlichen
bereiche unseres landes in den kabinett
wiederfinden und das mit klarer geist
eine ostdeutsche ministerin wird das ist
auch etwas ganz ganz bedeutendes
übrigens auch im hinblick auf dieses
ganz konkrete ressort das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen und wie schon
angekündigt werden wäre dann die
weiteren entscheidungen treffen in
hinblick zum beispiel auf die
parlamentarischen staatssekretäre
staatssekretär und die staatsministerin
staatsminister und auch das wird noch
mal eine weitere gelegenheit sein klar
zu machen wie wir genau zu den dingen
stehen die wir vorher gesagt haben wir
setzen sie ihnen nicht um
die nächste frage tim braune
herr scholz am donnerstag findet eine
erneute ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zur
pandemie statt
sehen sie noch bedarf für
nachbesserungen für feintuning gegenüber
dem vorangegangenen beschluss und noch
eine frage zur lage in ostdeutschland
dort haben viele leute die bilder
ersetzt als einen fackel tragen da mob
vor das haus von frau klatten gezogen
ist besorgt sie diese lage und vor allen
dingen auch vor dem hintergrund der
diskussion um die einführung einer
allgemeinen pflicht
zunächst einmal will ich auf die letzte
frage eingehen die sie dort gestellt
haben aus meiner sicht ist das ganz
furchtbar was wir dafür bilder gesehen
haben wir noch viel furchtbarer ist da
was passiert ist und das dürfen wir uns
als land nicht gefallen lassen ich finde
das ist die ganz klare botschaft die von
uns allen ausgehen muss als
demokratinnen und demokraten und deshalb
bin ich sehr sehr sicher dass ich da
nicht alleine stehe und auch nicht die
sozialdemokratische partei sondern viele
andere das entschieden zurückweisen
werden für mich ist es so dass wir auch
niemanden damit durchkommen lassen
dürfen dass er irgendwie
vergrätzt ist und deshalb solche dinge
tun darf in der welt in der wir leben
gibt es viele sachen die wir
unterschiedliche meinungen haben können
müssen und dürfen wir diskutieren und
natürlich ist es auch erlebt erlaubt
engagiert zu diskutieren aber dass das
ist als bedrohung gemeint und das
sollten wir sollten nicht so tun als ob
es nicht auch genau das gewesen ist eine
bedrohung an der demokratischen
fleißigen und ganz tollen politikerin in
sachsen und das ist unser geschäft als
alle demokraten demokraten dass wir das
zurückweisen
ansonsten gilt für die pandemie dass es
niemals den punkt geht wo man alles
getan hat und deshalb werden wir bei all
den beratungen die wir demnächst haben
immer diese frage neu wegen muss noch
etwas gemacht werden bin froh über die
dramatischen fortschritten die wir
letzte woche erzielt haben die jetzt ja
genau in den gesetzgebungsprozess
einbinden und mütze nicht steht da
hinten der fraktionsvorsitzende
sozialdemokratische partei und er kämpft
gerade sehr sehr engagiert dafür dass
das auch ein sehr schnelles
gesetzgebungsverfahren wird damit die
instrumente über die wir dort geredet
haben auch allen rechtzeitig zur
verfügung stünden ich würde ja gerne zu
mehr parität auch bei den fragen
aufwerfe aufrufen jetzt aber erstmal
gordon repinski mit der vorletzten frage
ja herr scholz und frau feser zwei kurze
fragen fräser sie sind für viele eine
überraschende personalie weil man sie
eigentlich auf dem schirm hatte als
spitzenkandidatin für die hessische
landtagswahl in zwei jahren die wird die
frage gelöst haben sich darüber schon
gedanken gemacht und herr scholz
vielleicht noch eine frage carsten
schneider hatte die unterstützung der
ostdeutschen landesverbände viele arme
im kabinett gesehen das ist ja jetzt
nicht wo sehen sie carsten schneider
fragen vielleicht darf ich da kurz zu
balken auch was sagen es ist klar hier
wird einen kabinettsposten besetzt um
den geht es ja zu der wird wahrgenommen
das ist eine sache die man mit langer
perspektive vorantreiben muss und alle
anderen fragen werden in hessen
entschieden wenn sie soweit sind ich
glaube das ist das was sich berichten
kann nach aus unseren gesprächen und
ansonsten habe ich ja schon gesagt dass
wir alle als sozialdemokratische partei
unsere große aufgabe sehen in der
regierung in der fraktion aber natürlich
auch im handy auf all die weiteren
aufgaben die noch konkret von uns
wahrgenommen werden müssen das ist ja
jetzt ein ganz ganz intensives geschäft
nicht so wie den usa wo tausende stellen
wie in einem klassischen prozesse neu
besetzt werden aber es sind schon eine
ganze menge und mein persönliches credo
ist das sehr sehr gut zu machen und da
kann ich ihnen sagen dass ich das im
tiefsten einvernehmen mache auch mit
carsten schneider und auch mit den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der
sozialdemokratischen partei also die
sind ganz ganz wichtig dafür dass uns
diese sache in den nächsten jahren
gelingt und das werden sie auch merken
bei all dem was wir noch zu entscheiden
haben
bei lautern braucht nur eine frage an
sie ein ganz besonderes augenmerk wird
darauf liegen welche akzente sie als
neuer bundesgesundheitsminister in der
pandemie bekämpfung setzen wollen können
sie uns das mal ein bisschen ihre
gedanken mitteilen und was glauben sie
welche rolle krone für unser
weihnachtsfest spielen wird
frage hast du direkt an karl lauterbach
gerichtet dass ich sie nicht einfach
beantworten will aber wir haben uns
vorgenommen dass wir ein bisschen jetzt
den anstand waren aus unserer sicht
jedenfalls und am mittwoch wird eine
regierung gebildet und dann stehen in
diese frauen und männer als
ministerinnen und minister zur verfügung
aber ich denke mal zwei sätze so ganz
klar sagen was ihre forderung und jetzt
natürlich stehen muss dass wir in den
wochen die wir noch haben die fallzahlen
so stark absenken dass wir möglichst
gute weihnachtsferien feiern können und
auch reisen können also ein wichtiges
ziel muss sein die fallzahlen so stark
herunter zu bringen dass wir ohne die
menschen zu gefährden reisen empfehlen
können darf wenn der werden großen wert
legen
schönen dank für ihr interesse und sie
werden diese frauen und männer noch
öfter sehen und in allen details kennen
lernen wie wir finden es sind sehr gute
frauen und männer
der und den zukünftigen
gesundheitsminister haben wir in seiner
position gerade schon gesehen karl
lauterbach wurde schon direkt bei der
vorstellung inhaltlich gefragt zudem wie
denn die nächsten corona wochen sein
werden und wie sie politisch zu
gestalten sind das war live aus der spd
parteizentrale in berlin aus dem
willy-brandt-haus die vorstellung der
neuen ministerinnen und minister durch
olaf scholz einblick in den chat zeigt
dass hier viel positive kommentare sind
für karl lauterbach
hier schreibt zum beispiel michael
häring über facebook herr lauterbach ist
perfekt für das abend ich gratuliere und
förstina schreibt ebenfalls über youtube
wenn einer corona besiegen kann dann
kann also hier sehr viel zuspruch und
heidi lehmann schreibt ebenfalls über
youtube an alle herzlichen glückwunsch
an alle neuen ministerinnen und minister
dann bröseln wir das im einzelnen mal
auf werden in der neuen bundesregierung
sitzen wird zusammen mit der
politikwissenschaftlerin frau professor
andrea römmele von der hertie school of
governance
zugeschaltet aus berlin noch einmal
guten morgen frau professor ulrich
dekliniert gerade noch mal schnell durch
für alle die jetzt erst eingeschaltet
haben sieben neue ministerinnen und
minister drei männer vier frauen nancy
faeser aus hessen wird die erste
innenministerin hubertus heil bleibt
arbeitsminister christine lambrecht wird
verteidigungsministerin
lauterbach wird gesundheitsminister
klara geywitz neue ministerin für bauen
und wohnen
svenja schulze bisher umweltministerin
wird
entwicklungsministerin und wolfgang
schmidt wird kanzleramtsminister um wie
er gerade gesagt hat das zu tun was olaf
scholz jetzt tun möchte nämlich gut
dieses land regieren und wolfgang
schmidt wird ihm dafür den rücken
freihalten frau professor wille ihre
einschätzung zu dieser minister innen
riege
meine erste einschätzung so ein bisschen
über diese präsentation der spd
ministerinnen und minister hinaus wenn
man sich das gesamte kabinett jetzt
anschaut muss man sagen die
internationale politik ist frauensache
was mich jetzt auch persönlich freut
wenn ich da meine persönliche meinung an
dieser stelle ganz kurz einschließen
lassen dafür haben eine außenministerin
wir haben das haben wir jetzt gerade
gehört eine
verteidigungsministerin mit frau
lamprecht auch das innenministerium und
das entwicklungsministerium geht an
frauen und insofern muss man jetzt auch
sagen angela merkel hat deutschland
verändert das wäre vor zehn jahren vor
15 jahren noch nicht so denkbar und
möglich gewesen das vielleicht als als
mein erster ganz großer eindruck dann
hat olaf scholz eine ministerinnen und
minister riege zusammengestellt die
kontinuität und erneuerung und
gleichzeitig ist er hat mit frau
lamprecht mit frau schulze und
herfahren ministerinnen und minister und
hat aber auch neuzugänge mit frau
gallwitz mit frau
feser und karl lauterbach
kanzleramtsminister wolfgang schmidt hat
große erfahrung natürlich schon als
staatssekretär aus dem
finanzministerium und ist glaube ich so
ein bisschen dazwischen anzusiedeln die
große oder vielleicht auch nicht so
große überraschung karl lauterbach der
sich ja auch ganz ausdrücklich in seiner
ganz kurzen ansprache bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern bedankt hat und
ich habe ihm dann auf twitter gleich
einmal den hashtag minister der herzen
gegeben eine kluge entscheidung meiner
ansicht nach karl lauterbach hier
zunehmend bei ministerinnen und
ministern geht es ja auch zu einem ganz
großen maße um
management-erfahrung also kann er oder
kann sie so ein haus wo ein ministerium
auch führen fach expertise kann man sich
dazu holen kann man sich vor allem auf
der ebene der staatssekretärinnen und
staatssekretäre kann man sich da aus
rissen aber gerade in einer pandemie ist
eben die sachkompetenz die expertise
auch auf diesem level erforderlich und
karl lauterbach hat es in den letzten
wochen und monaten gezeigt dass er eine
unglaubliche expertise eine ruhe in der
krise und eben auch das vertrauen der
bevölkerung genießt insofern ein kluger
schachzug von olaf scholz
wir können vielleicht gerade mal einen
blick auf einen monitor hier werfen dann
sehen wir auch ihren tweet frau
professor rummel hier andrea römmele auf
twitter sehen wir vor 16 minuten olaf
scholz stellt die sieben spd
ministerinnen und minister vor hashtag
lauterbach dankt ausdrücklich den
bürgerinnen und bürgern hashtag minister
der herzen schauen wir mal ob sie damit
einen trend gesetzt haben heute
warten wir mal ab ob professor remmele
ich würde gerne mit ihnen über die spd
noch mal sprechen an diesem tag heute
wenn wir uns angucken woher die partei
kam wir erinnern uns 20,5 prozent bei
der letzten bundestagswahl das war ein
desaströses ergebnis landtagswahlen eine
klatsche nach der anderen für die spd
und jetzt heute diese partei die diese
ministerinnen und minister vorstellt mit
einer unglaublichen lockerheit muss man
sagen wenn man sich auch diesen auftritt
anguckt irgendwie alle frei geredet alle
als team auf dieser bühne und mit einem
großem selbstbewusstsein was es mit
dieser partei passiert
diese partei ist geeint diese partei
steht hinter ihrem
spitzenkandidaten jetzt bald kanzler
diese partei ist auch bereit
verantwortung zu übernehmen und hat
einfach in der krise
sich extrem gut aufgestellt kann man
nicht anders sagen
der ein exzellenter orchestrierte
wahlkampf der natürlich auch von den
fehlern der anderen parteien profitiert
hat hat die partei jetzt dahin gebracht
wo sie steht sie hat gut ausgebildetes
personal und steht jetzt vor einer der
größten herausforderungen vor der wir
als land jetzt auch stehen und olaf
scholz hat ja auch selbst
mehrere male in interviews gesagt dass
wir in den nächsten zehn jahren vor der
größten transformation bestehen die wir
in den letzten 100 jahren zu bewältigen
haben und parallel dazu muss olaf scholz
die regierung scholz jetzt diese vierte
welle managen also beachtliche aufgaben
die da vor der großen koalition jetzt
nicht nur vor der spd sondern eben auch
vor der gesamten ampel stehen zum
abschluss noch eine letzte frage dazu
wie sehr diese einigkeit denn bestand
haben wird wir haben am wochenende kevin
kühnert gehört den designierten
generalsekretär der gesagt hat die
partei muss offen bleiben hungrig
bleiben so hat er das formuliert und auf
gesellschaftliche debatten eingehen und
auch dinge vorantreiben die nicht im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart sind wie
sehr
wird denn die partei olaf scholz stützen
in seinen entscheidungen und wie sehr
wird sie ihm auch dazwischen grätschen
wenn wir uns angucken in der
bundestagsfraktion sind ein drittel
jusos das kann für olaf scholz ganz
schön schwierig werden ja es ist ein
spagat den olaf scholz machen muss man
darf ja nicht vergessen er ist ja
ist ja damals auch mit klara geywitz als
duo angetreten wo für den parteivorsitz
ist dann nicht gewählt worden also eine
eine knallharte niederlage die die er
einstecken musste
kanzlerschaft und parteivorsitz sind
nicht in einer hand was immer schwierig
gewesen ist es zeigt uns die geschichte
ob wir da auf die spd schauen oder auch
die auf die cdu saar olaf scholz hat
aber mit lars klingbeil einen engen
vertrauten und weggefährten mit dem er
sich glaube ich blind die bälle
zuspielen kann natürlich ein drittel der
bundestagsfraktion ist
gehört dem linken flügel der spd an umso
klüger ist es natürlich auch gewesen
kevin kühnert jetzt als generalsekretär
aufzustellen um so
diesen flügel der partei eben auch zu
repräsentieren und gehör zu verschaffen
sagt frau professor andrea römmele
vielen dank für diese einschätzungen an
diesem montagmorgen zum auftrag eine
wirklich spannenden woche danke jungs
[Musik]